have you seen those Detroit self-defense
videos
uh yeah I think oh I know I have I'm
trying to think how I saw him but yeah
because a lot of Jiu Jitsu people will
will repost those things yeah what what
do you think that people misunderstand
when it comes to life and death fights
street fights what do you think most
normal people who haven't been in one
misbelief
I don't know what that has to do with
those Detroit videos those Detroit
videos are definitely uh
it's a pantomime yeah so I I guess
so I I guess what to answer your
question what do most people not
understand about a street fight uh
they're probably not used to just the
level of violence that's going to occur
they're not they're maybe this is maybe
this is what you're getting out with the
Detroit uh
self-defense videos or whatever they are
the choreographed Maneuvers that you
that work when you and I are going
through them and sort of dancing those
aren't going to work in real life
and so if you think that you're going to
be able to drop someone with one punch
are you think all those things that that
that that are sort of the old
traditional martial arts doing Kata and
I you know I do this to you and it
causes this reaction then my next move
is over here yeah that stuff doesn't
really work in a street fight just yeah
the growing cake and the
palm of the hand to the nose to run away
from the the female to run away from the
attacker and stuff like that yep it's
not going to work well and it's not very
reliable
if you want to learn how to fight you
got to learn how to fight
you know you got to do Jiu Jitsu Muay
Thai Wrestling Boxing that's what you
need to do if you want to learn how to
fight
have you been to go and see what Tim
Kennedy's doing I put his place with his
self-defense courses I have not been to
one of his courses it's called sheepdog
response but I've seen what he's doing
and of course you know Tim's Tim's a not
only is he well-versed in martial arts
clearly he's also well versed in weapons
and he's also well-versed in violence
and so I know
what he's teaching is legit stuff I'm
pretty sure they're using live handheld
tasers as well during that to just show
people precisely how difficult it is to
whatever do the the face palm and the
eye gouge and the Fish Hook can run away
and uh
I think he runs I think it must be
monthly he does a special one for
not military personnel for
um
the police and um
even them the amount of training I think
I mean we've seen this recently right
that the training seems to be
insufficient yeah the training for
police officers is totally insufficient
and it's it's horrible because it's a
very difficult job that you should be
training I I've been saying for the last
several years that police officers
should train 20 of the time
20 of the time that they work they
should be training and
right now it's not even it's probably
not even a measurable percentage of time
that they're working I mean it's
probably in the fractions of a percent
that they're training they get horrible
training and they're in really Dynamic
situations and in doing an incredibly
hard job
you don't know how to do that stuff you
know that's you talked about the
misconceptions of the street fight is
the person that thinks well you know
when I if someone messes with me I'm
just gonna get wild and they think
that's going to work and that's not
gonna work especially getting someone
that's trained
so if you think that you're gonna have
some magical powers because you're angry
or because your adrenaline's going
that's not that's not true and it's
gonna it's gonna cost you in a big way
especially if you come up against
somebody like Tim Kennedy who's
genuinely trained oh for sure yeah and
and you know this day and age well I
mean I live in San Diego California
a lot of people train a lot of people
train I wouldn't say it's the majority
of people train but there are a lot if
you get no fight in San Diego there's a
decent chance you're fighting against
someone that knows how to fight
and the look there's Jiu Jitsu on every
street in San Diego Jiu Jitsu academies
so
yeah if you just think you're going to
be a tough guy
it's it's going to be rough it's going
to be a rough tour what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
face